hey guys i'm ashley tisdale and i'm at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to talk about my
first time I'm kind of nervous cuz I'm
like don't know what the questions are I
don't know what first times I'm gonna
share with you right now but we're gonna
dive in what would be the first hsm song
you to race from everyone oh yeah what
would it be during the concert I think
it was called can't take my eyes off of
you I just saw was like not a great song
and I was like what are we doing with
this song it's like this is not even in
any of the movies yeah not a fan of that
one sorry Tara the writer Wilma oh I
shoulda said home home and it kind of
got lost okay describe your first red
carpet experience oh my first red carpet
experience I remember wearing flip-flops
and RV fatigue pants and I was like this
is what I'm gonna wear to a red carpet
I'm so cool she was mad at me for
something and I can't really remember
what it was I first item you took from a
set all of Sharpay's wardrobe from the
first movie did I think I was gonna wear
them on the red carpet probably at that
time I was like yeah a lot of our
clothes are in like Hall of Fame's and
they didn't have Sharpay stuff and
Disney tried so hard to get the clothes
from me and I was like no this is mine
so yeah they don't have any of the
clothes from the first movie I do tell
us not the first time you got turned
down for a role you really wanted Wow
there's been so many I auditioned for a
lot of Disney movies one of them was
Zenon Wilma Chawla buff I can't remember
what was called it was a really serious
one I just would always like be last to
and I would never get it and I was so
bummed out that I like didn't even
audition for Disney for a long time and
then to get the High School Musical
movie I mean out of all of them I'm so
glad I got that one that was like the
best experience so I gotta keep going oh
yeah that was it yeah yeah they always
would go to the Disney girl first time
you realized you were famous I grew up
in Valencia California and I was back
there at like a signing at the mall that
I used to actually work in I used to
work at Wet Seal and I worked at Windsor
and I become me and Fitch in Hollister
they're obviously the high school
musical just come out and I remember it
being like so insane I went to like one
of my favorite stores and they had to
shut down the store and there are people
like banging on the glass thousands of
kids and they were there just trying to
like get into the store and I was just
like whoa like this is crazy especially
being at a place where just like a
couple months ago no one knew who I was
it was pretty kind of weird and awesome
at the same time I was just like wow
this is definitely different this is
crazy first Howard rumor you heard about
yourself I remember people thinking that
Zac and I dated because we were like on
a lot of magazine covers together cuz we
were promoting the first movie and so we
just thought that was like really funny
because he was obviously dating someone
else and he's my best friend okay
describe the first song you've ever
written suddenly off of headstrong that
was the first song I've ever written it
was really personal it was still so new
for me so it's really cool because I
have co-written every single song on
this album symptoms and I'm just so much
more confident as an artist and
confident in my lyrics that I've grown a
lot since that first time so it's really
cool to see that evolution I had so much
fun answering those questions very good
ones
thank you guys so much for having me
thank you BuzzFeed I hope you liked my
answers to all my first-time questions
my single voices in my head is out right
now check it out bye first celebrity
crush ooh
Hansen was my first concert and I
thought I was going to marry Zack Hansen
I was like he's the one for me